groups of protesters spread across the
city Monday morning successfully
blockading some of Washington DC's major
roads protest organizers said they knew
some DC residents may not be happy but a
climate emergency calls for drastic
action the blockades that happened
impacted and we're targeted to impact
the the powerful people the people who
are able to make decision decisions that
people who have been blocking climate
action and in ordinary people in DC deal
with disruptions all the time the
difference today is that the people the
powerful people are experiencing a
disruption a series of blockades did
manage to shut down many of the main
arteries off Washington DC his
Independence Avenue which has been shut
down as a result of the protests
currently going on behind me that can no
more be any business as usual the
protesters keep saying one of the goals
of the protesters was to emphasize how
climate change intersects with other
issues for example this protest shut
down the roads around the Immigration
and Customs Enforcement headquarters
because they're suffering down south
because of all the trees that are being
chopped because of all the oil that's
being drilled everyone is moving up
right so they're trying to move into
first world places at this intersection
medical professionals join forces with
the black lives matter movement to
emphasize the connections between
environmental justice and action against
racism and the need for wider access to
health care they build in a drill and
pollute the air affecting the lungs in
the life of marginalized black and brown
people our people are being displaced
because they're not fixing the problems
of lead and Mo in our apartments and
housing the protesters blame the late
capitalist models are putting profits
ahead of the planet and endorse what's
called a green new deal as the basis for
a fundamental reshaping of the US
economy
slashing emissions and investing in
renewable energy while also investing in
communities around the country to ensure
no one is left behind as the economy
transitions to environmental
sustainability and the several hours at
least the urgency of the climate
emergency was on display on the streets
of Washington DC she Everett ANSI al
Jazeera Washington